one of the big issues there is where
does the energy come from to power up a
huge indoor farming operation so in the
middle of the Arizona desert the Sun
supplies everything they don't grow food
at night and so they don't use grow
lights they don't have to they get an
abundant amount of sunlight and because
it's double skinned glass it's insulated
from the outside so if the temperature
goes 220 they don't care and in the
winter if it goes down to minus 10 they
don't care it's still 75 to 80 degrees
inside of their vertical and inside
their horizontal greenhouse alright no
one's ever done this up okay because
there are engineering challenges as well
as some economic challenges but it's
mostly engineering so but if you grow
food indoors in these big buildings well
how much energy will it consume vs in
fact how much might it even generate by
the parts of the plants that you don't
eat you can recycle that and get some of
that back at least so that was the fifth
year's project for the students I'm no
fool i don't know the answers to these
questions you know I parasitized their
brains and all I was going to say the
reason we should behave as a single
species and not as 194 different species
is because we are a single species and
our brain is basically engineered the
same way regardless if you're an
Aborigine living in the middle of the
australian desert or if you're an IBM
executive up in Rye New York trying to
find out what the next alternate power
source might be the fact is that if you
could connect those genomes together
into a single thinking unit that's 6.7
billion inputs with about a hundred
trillion neuronal connections per input
I don't care what the problem is I don't
care what the problem is it's solved in
a minute it's that solid an hour it's
not so now I give you examples of where
that actually works on a small scale the
International ladies garment workers
union it's a wonderful example of a
cooperate
among a group of people that agrees at a
common end we are going to behave
together we'll take pay cuts will get
pay raises but no one loses their job
and we'll all produce clothing as the
end of the day that's our job and that's
what we're going to do the engineering
company of our up aru p is a fabulous
example of how to behave there are i
don't know how many engineers they have
on their staff there in thirty seven
different countries every engineer can
access any other engineers problem and
there's a blog and they go on the blog
and say you don't i don't know how to do
this I I didn't have this in school or
or aim this has never been encountered
before help and you know 15 people will
go on the blog and say oh you know I and
you know what the next day the problem
is solved so they never say I can't do
that that just can't be done ha it'll
never fly it'll never float it'll never
you put that word it'll never blah blah
blah blah blah next I wanted somebody
else sitting here I don't want to talk
to it can never I want to talk to when
can you that's what I want to hear when
can you build me a vertical farm and so
I've now I've heard that from about
eight places for of these places are for
real and one of those places will be
first and could I tell you which one
that is no I can't because I don't know
yet and if I did I would tell you so we
have we have a lot of money sitting out
there waiting to get involved in this
because they they have sort of ignored
the concept of profitability and they're
concentrating on need and I think
profitability will follow need so when
people see how good their food is and
how abundant it is and how readily
available it is the switch well I would
never eat anything growing on outside I
can't trust the outdoors I can't control
it everything you can want is controlled
indoors and I think marketing will be a
no-brainer once it starts
you